one of the questions I get all the time
is how do you get into law school
everyone has a different route but today
I thought I'd tell the story of how I
got into one of the best law schools in
the country
[Music]
hey legal eagles D James Stone here
teaching you how to think like a lawyer
so you can crush law school now before
you can crush law school you have to get
into law school now I have been a
practicing litigator for over 10 years
now but before that I had to go to law
school just like everybody else and so
here is my story I knew from a very
early age that I wanted to be a lawyer
there was a brief period of time when I
thought I wanted to be a policeman but
when I learned that police officers are
not allowed to carry machine guns I
didn't really want to become a policeman
after all there was a short period of
time when I wanted to be an architect
but that didn't last too long mainly
because I started to see lawyers on TV I
was really into the TV show law and
order now this is back in a day with the
original Law & Order series not the SVU
or any of the offshoots when they would
split up the episode into half that was
for police and then half for lawyers and
I always thought the latter half of the
episode that focused only on the lawyers
was always the best part and I knew I
wanted to be a lawyer like I saw on TV
there was only one problem my parents
put a hard limit on how much TV
I could watch I think I was only able to
watch 30 minutes of recreational TV but
I was able to watch an unlimited amount
of educational TV so in one of my first
acts of pure legal argument I convinced
my parents that because I wanted to be a
lawyer
really law and order was educational TV
and I should be allowed to watch as much
law and order as I wanted for some
reason this argument carried the day and
my parents agreed and this is back in
the day when TBS or TNT one of those
cable channels would just show law and
order basically non-stop I mean these
were almost during the daytime the
law-and-order channel and so I had a
chance to watch quite a bit of law and
order and that provided the goal for
what I wanted to do with my career I
think my parents assumed two things
based on my arguments number one I think
they assumed that if I was willing to
make these kind of arguments that I was
really interested in the law and so what
could it do and number two that they
figured I was pretty good at arguing so
that led into high school where I did
mock trial in high school I was really
mad because my freshman year they would
not let freshmen compete on the mock
trial team so I had to wait until my
sophomore year graduated from high
school went to college and I chose the
college that I went to because they had
one of the best collegiate Mock Trial
teams in the entire country and in fact
while I was on the college team we won
the national championship twice in a row
in college I majored in Poli Sci mainly
because I was interested in but it
really seemed like so many lawyers had
also majored in political science so I
figured if other lawyers majored in Poli
Sci it probably couldn't hurt a lot of
people ask what majors they should take
in college they see the same thing that
lots of lawyers take Poli Sci I would
say that the Poli Sci degree was really
interesting for me because it was
interesting I put a lot of effort into
it and so I got good grades but it
definitely didn't really help in terms
of preparing for law school itself just
because you know about government
doesn't mean that you know what the laws
are or and it certainly doesn't mean
that you're able to think like a lawyer
just because you know some of the
history of governance and maybe even
some political theory so Wow I really
enjoyed my Poli Sci degree I don't
really think it helped me all that much
in law school but frankly
no major really helps you that much in
law school really what you should do is
just the major that you are most
interested in so that you can get good
grades because law schools look at your
grades and that helps decide what law
school you can go to now that being said
I did take a number of electives that
did end up being helpful for law school
one of which was a business class that
was taught by my Mock Trial coach my
Mock Trial coach was not only a
professor at the undergraduate level but
he was also a professor at the the
Business School and he happened to teach
business law classes these were mainly
for business students but undergrads
could take it and while it wasn't a
great survey of all the different types
of substantive law that are out there
that you learned in law school it did
provide a framework for what we call a
Civil Procedure in law school in law
school you have six core classes one of
which is called sim Pro and that's the
process of filing a lawsuit and how to
file motions and basically everything
that leads up to going to trial in a law
suit and so that gave me a framework for
that specific class in Civil Procedure
so I'm really happy that I took that
that business law class I did pretty
well in general in undergrad I graduated
summa [ __ ] laude Phi Beta Kappa and was
was able to graduate with honors from
UCLA undergrad now I knew that when I
graduated I immediately wanted to go to
law school I couldn't afford to do a gap
year and to travel the world and I knew
that I didn't want to enter the
workforce because that would just be a
waste of time because I really wanted to
be an attorney so I didn't want to mess
around I wanted to go straight into law
school so basically from the entire time
that I graduated from college for the
entire summer and a good portion of the
fall I studied for the LSAT and I think
I might have started studying for the
LSAT during the school year to get a
head start the LSAT is
to law schools what the SAT is for
college it's it's your law school
entrance exam it really is the single
most important thing that you can do to
get into a good law school is to get a
really high LSAT score and the LSAT is
scored from zero to 180 so if you get a
perfect score on the LSAT you get a 180
the LSAT is scored I think using a
normal distribution so really only the
top you know 0.1 or 0.5 percent get a
180 if you get a 170 that means you're
in the 99th percentile and if you get a
160 or so you're about in the 90th
percentile and tens of thousands of
college students take the LSAT every
year so I had taken a couple of practice
tests practice LSAT
just to see how I scored and I scored
really low just with no studying
whatsoever so I knew that I needed to
take a prep course in order to boost my
score to get into a good law school
there are several good options out there
right now I highly recommend live
courses the the ones that force you to
go into the class and force you to study
as opposed to the ones that are
self-directed because you know it's it's
so important that you really have to
squeeze out every point you can and I
just didn't trust myself to study on my
own at least to learn the strategies I
took a course with a company called test
master that was based out of California
I think they've expanded nationally now
I took their live class and I was
actually instructed by one of the
instructors who would go on to form the
competitor to test masters called
blueprint and I think those instructors
were just phenomenally the original test
masters instructors and also the ones
that defected and went off to to
blueprint I think they are really
phenomenal so I always recommend those
two companies and especially their live
courses they are they're really pricey I
mean on the order of 1,500 to 2,000
dollars but the instruction that you get
is is just really
and it's an investment in your future
you can't get into a good law school
without a really stellar LSAT score so I
think it's it's just a worthwhile
investment it's expensive but I think
you just have to do it after I took the
live class with test masters I then
basically buckled down with my college
roommate and we practiced taking L SATs
every day for about two and a half
months I mean we just we studied all day
every day and by the end of the summer
we had taken every single publicly
available LSAT that had been published
so that was on the order of hundreds of
L SATs and both he and I were were
scoring in the 99th percentile he
averaged I think 174 and I average of
172 so I went into the LSAT feeling very
confident
unfortunately the day I took the LSAT
still can't really explain it but I
scored significantly lower than I had in
practice I scored in the mid-16th still
pisses me off to this day but the score
was high enough that I could apply to
most of the schools that I wanted to
apply to and have a reasonably good shot
at getting into a few of them so I
applied to pretty much every school in
the top 20 and some of the schools that
were outside of the top 20 but were
regionally very good I I knew for
personal reasons that I wanted to stay
in Los Angeles so I was really really
looking to get into UCLA I was also
looking at USC I also looked at Loyola
and Pepperdine I considered some East
Coast schools some Northern California
schools and I basically just applied
everywhere in the top 20 s hoping that a
few of them would stick against the wall
and that summer I I got into a few and I
was wait-listed at a few I got
wait-listed at Cornell Duke and UCLA I
got into Loyola and pepper
so I knew I could stay in Los Angeles if
I wanted to my study partner my roommate
scored a 172 on his exam or might have
been 170 so he was safely within the
99th percentile of the LSAT and he got
into Stanford through early admission so
good for him but I played the waitlist
game for most of the summer and for
personal reasons I wanted to stay in LA
so I was really hoping to get into UCLA
and USC now that being said since I was
an undergrad UCLA Bruin I was really
really reluctant about going to USC
nothing against the school it's it's a
fine school
it's just that UCLA Bruins hate USC
Trojans and vice-versa so I decided I
would even though I got into USC I was
still playing the wait list game over
the summer hoping that I could get in
off the waitlist into UCLA so eventually
a few weeks before school started I was
looking for apartments close to the USC
campus I had resigned myself to going to
USC in downtown LA and I actually signed
a lease in Hollywood I figured that was
a reasonably close neighborhood to
downtown LA and it was the day that I
signed the lease for an apartment in
Hollywood that I got the call from UCLA
admissions letting me know that I got in
off of the waitlist I did a few tactics
to get in off of the waitlist so I was
pestering the the UCLA admissions
department probably more than I should
have but my efforts paid off I got into
UCLA and that's where I decided to go I
graduated from UCLA law stayed in the LA
area and became a practicing attorney in
LA now the story of how I did well in
law school will have to wait for another
day but if you want to hear more about
my experience in law school and my
experience as a practicing litigator
check out this quick playlist I put
there includes a bunch of legal war
stories and so just click on that
playlist and I'll see you in the next
video